all these religions have the same
generalized scenario which goes
something like this in a time of great
crisis when governments are being shaken
when pestilence stalks the land when all
hope has been lost
then the Savior the Messiah the space
people the you name it will come and the
elect will be lifted up and carried away
to their rightful place at the throne of
the Galactic litter or Jesus or whatever
so I don't dismiss this I think it is an
intimation of the future and the
horrifying thing about it is that there
are people who are working to create it
I mean I think that there is in the
American psyche a freakish Fannett optic
drive to realize an apocalyptic scenario
and that there are you know it's been a
game in Western civilization to locate
the Antichrist I mean the frederick
barbarossa is the antichrist the emperor
charles v is the antichrist
oliver cromwell is the antichrist so
forth well a harmless game unless you
have thermonuclear delivery systems
where once you've located the Antichrist
you can just nuke the son of a [ __ ] and
and do the right thing and and today I
was driving down here this morning
listening to some screwball
fundamentalist going on and on about
Qaddafi the Antichrist was just here are
the signs and he did this and he did
that what Qaddafi is is some
or dictated of amount two pissants belch
you know but in the desire to find the
person ages that fit the apocalyptic
scenario all kinds of historical
distortion will take place and its
really frightening that a part of the
right-wing mentality in this country is
a real desire for this it was built in
to the Nazi thing you know I mean on one
level
Hitler talked about a thousand-year
German Reich and like that but when the
going got tough he could only reach back
into Nordic mythology and bulgarian
opera and say that the Gothard Amuro the
Ragnarok the twilight of the gods and
then once they saw once they accepted
that that was the destiny then the
destruction of Germany was really aided
and abetted by the decisions made by the
German General Staff in the last six
months of the war when they wanted an
apocalyptic orgy of destruction their
attitude was if not us nobody and that
attitude is a better red than dead
philosophy
you